Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. At 7.45 on the morning of Tuesday, August 16, 1988, 23-year-old Andrea Blecker was preparing to start her day in the west of German town of Glatbeck. She worked as a customer service representative at a branch of the Deutsche Bank, which was housed in a rectangular two-storey, brown brick building near the town centre.
我们的节目涉及严重且往往令人痛心的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。有关获取保密支持的建议电话号码，请查看您使用的应用上或我们网站上的本集节目简介。1988年8月16日星期二早上7点45分，23岁的安德烈娅·布莱克（Andrea Blecker）正准备在德国西部小镇格拉德贝克（Glatbeck）开始她的一天。她在德意志银行（Deutsche Bank）的一家分行担任客户服务代表，该分行位于镇中心附近一座长方形的两层棕色砖砌建筑内。
Glatbeck sat in the western state of North Rhine-Westphalia and had become a popular coal mining centre in the previous century. By the mid-1960s, that industry was on the decline and the town had been battling high unemployment levels ever since. As she approached the bank, Andrea greeted a 34-year-old colleague who worked as a teller and was also making his way towards the building. As the two of them reached the bank's glass doors, two masked men appeared out of nowhere. Both were carrying revolvers.
格拉德贝克位于西部的北莱茵-威斯特法伦州（North Rhine-Westphalia），在上个世纪曾是一个受欢迎的煤炭开采中心。到20世纪60年代中期，该行业一直在衰退，自那以后，该镇一直在与高失业率作斗争。当安德烈娅走近银行时，她向一位34岁的同事打招呼，这位同事是一名出纳员，也正朝着大楼走去。当两人到达银行的玻璃门时，两个蒙面男子凭空出现。两人都带着左轮手枪。
The men forced both bank employees into the building at gunpoint and threatened to shoot them. Inside, the bank was quiet and empty. It hadn't opened yet and there was no one else around. The gunman made it clear that this was an armed robbery and demanded a large sum of money. Having been trained to handle this exact situation, the two clerks provided them with 120,000 German marks.
这两名男子用枪逼着两名银行员工进入大楼，并威胁要开枪打死他们。银行内部安静而空旷。它还没开门，周围也没有其他人。持枪歹徒明确表示这是一起武装抢劫，并索要巨额现金。由于接受过处理这种确切情况的培训，两名店员向他们提供了12万德国马克。
The hold-up was going perfectly for the robbers. They had their money and the early hour made it likely that they'd escape quickly and without detection. Right outside, a witness had spotted the crime in progress and called the police. By 8.04am, officers had been dispatched to the scene and were lying in wait. As the two offenders made their way to the bank's front doors with their stolen loot, they spotted the police car parked nearby. Hastily, the two men retreated back inside.
劫匪的抢劫过程非常顺利。他们拿到了钱，而且由于时间尚早，他们很可能会迅速且不被察觉地逃跑。就在外面，一名目击者发现了正在进行的犯罪并报警。上午8点04分，警察已被派往现场并在那里埋伏。当两名罪犯带着赃物走向银行正门时，他们发现了停在附近的警车。两人匆忙退回室内。
They needed a new plan to secure their exit without getting arrested. They decided to take the two bank employees hostage. Robbing a bank had been an impromptu plan for the two men who were now hunkered down inside the Deutsche Bank. The leader of the pair was a notorious local criminal named Hans Jürgen Rosner. He'd had his first brush with the law at the age of 14 and had a reputation for violent behaviour and a domineering personality. After being convicted of robbery and assault, he'd spent 11 years in prison.
他们需要一个新计划来确保在不被捕的情况下撤离。他们决定将两名银行员工劫为人质。抢劫银行对这两个现在躲在德意志银行内部的男子来说是一个即兴的计划。这对组合的头目是一个名叫汉斯·于尔根·罗斯纳（Hans Jürgen Rosner）的臭名昭著的当地罪犯。他在14岁时就第一次触犯法律，并以暴力行为和专制个性而闻名。在因抢劫和袭击罪被定罪后，他在监狱里度过了11年。
During his incarceration, he stabbed a guard in the neck and had a couple more years added to his sentence. Eventually, he was released on parole, but had disappeared after going on the run. Local law enforcement had been keeping an eye out for him ever since, to no avail. Rosner was now 31 years old, with a scruffy beard and messy brown hair that was longer in the back but receding at the front. A yellow tank top exposed his heavily tattooed arms and he wore baggy blue jeans. He'd spent the previous night drinking with his accomplice, 32-year-old Dieter Degovsky.
在他服刑期间，他刺伤了一名警卫的脖子，刑期又被加了几年。最终，他获得假释出狱，但在潜逃后失踪了。自那以后，当地执法部门一直在留意他，但徒劳无功。罗斯纳现在31岁，留着蓬乱的胡子和凌乱的棕色头发，后面较长但前面发际线后移。一件黄色的背心露出了他纹身密集的胳膊，他穿着宽松的蓝色牛仔裤。前一天晚上，他一直和同伙、32岁的迪特尔·德戈夫斯基（Dieter Degovsky）喝酒。
The two men had met at school and were lifelong friends. Degovsky had a quieter, more nervous personality but a similarly substantial rap sheet. Like Rosner, he had receding brown hair, a beard and numerous tattoos, though his were concealed by a long-sleeved checked shirt. At six that morning, at the end of their all-night drinking session, the two friends had suddenly decided to try their luck at robbing a bank. They'd made their way into town on a moped and waited until they spotted the two Deutsche Bank employees.
这两个人在学校相识，是终身的朋友。德戈夫斯基性格更安静、更紧张，但犯罪记录同样丰富。和罗斯纳一样，他也有后退的棕色头发、胡须和众多纹身，尽管他的纹身被一件长袖格子衬衫遮住了。早上六点，在他们通宵饮酒结束时，这两个朋友突然决定碰碰运气去抢劫银行.他们骑着轻便摩托车进城，直到他们发现了两名德意志银行的员工。
Then, they struck. Now, caught off guard by the arrival of police, Rosner and Degovsky frantically concocted a backup plan. They would let officers know they were holding people captive and negotiate a deal in exchange for their freedom. The men made contact with the police via the bank's telephone and informed them that they had guns and two hostages. Their victims would only be freed if police supplied a BMW getaway car and an additional
然后，他们动手了。现在，被警察的到来搞得措手不及，罗斯纳和德戈夫斯基拼命拼凑出一个备用计划。他们会告诉警察他们扣留了人质，并以自由为筹码进行谈判。这两人通过银行的电话与警方取得联系，并通知他们他们有枪和两个人质。只有在警方提供一辆宝马逃跑轿车和额外的汽车的情况下，他们的受害者才会被释放。
300,000 German marks in small denominations. To prove that they had weapons and should be considered dangerous, they fired their revolver through the bank's windows, shattering the glass. To prevent officers storming the building and thwarting their plan, Rosner and Degovsky forced their two hostages into the bank's bulletproof cash office, then followed them in. The police responded by bringing in a psychologist to call the bank and try to talk the men into revealing their identities.
30万德国马克小面额。为了证明他们有武器并且应该被认为是危险的，他们通过银行的窗户开枪射击，震碎了玻璃。为了防止警察冲进大楼并破坏他们的计划，罗斯纳和德戈夫斯基强行将两名人质推进了银行的防弹现金办公室，然后跟了进去。警方通过带进一名心理学家打电话给银行并试图说服这些人透露他们的身份来回应。
Rosner and Degovsky called on to the ploy and refused to speak to the police any further. Instead, they demanded to speak to the bank's director and ordered that he organize the car and ransom money himself. Despite the robbers' refusal to name themselves, police were able to ID Hans Jürgen Rosner and deduced correctly that his accomplice was his longtime friend, Dieter Degovsky. Mindful that both men were known for being volatile and dangerous, they decided their best course of action was to go along with their demands. It took them a while to organize the cash.
罗斯纳和德戈夫斯基识破了这个花招，拒绝与警方进一步交谈。相反，他们要求与银行行长对话，并下令由他亲自安排汽车和赎金。尽管劫匪拒绝说出自己的名字，但警方还是认出了汉斯·于尔根·罗斯纳，并正确推断出他的同伙是他的老朋友迪特尔·德戈夫斯基。考虑到这两个人都以反复无常和危险著称，他们决定采取的最佳行动是顺应他们的要求。他们花了一段时间来整理现金。
Before handing it over, police treated the banknotes with a solution that would leave traces on whoever handled it. That way, they'd have evidence pointing to the culprits when they managed to arrest them. The process was a lengthy one, adding to the high stress of the urgent situation. While police scrambled to get the funds ready, the men continued to call the bank's director, demanding to know why it hadn't arrived yet. Tensions further increased when police realized they couldn't source a BMW as the robbers' getaway car.
在交出现金之前，警方用一种溶液处理了这些纸币，这种溶液会在任何经手这些纸币的人身上留下痕迹。这样，当他们设法逮捕罪犯时，他们就会有指向罪犯的证据。这是一个漫长的过程，增加了紧急情况下的巨大压力。当警察争分夺秒地准备资金时，这些人继续打电话给银行行长，要求知道为什么资金还没到。当警方意识到他们找不到一辆宝马作为劫匪的逃跑汽车时，紧张局势进一步加剧。
The only vehicles available were Audi's. Rosner and Degovsky grew increasingly anxious as they waited, and the police became nervous that they might lash out against their hostages. Time continued to pass as law enforcement struggled to meet the robbers' demands. By 2pm, the hostages had been holed up inside the bank with their captors for more than six hours. By now, the press had caught wind of the story. Word had filtered out that there was an ongoing standoff between two armed robbers and the
唯一可用的车辆是奥迪。罗斯纳和德戈夫斯基在等待时越来越焦虑，而警察则开始担心他们会对人质大打出手。随着执法部门努力满足劫匪的要求，时间继续流逝。下午2点，人质已经和绑匪一起被困在银行里超过六个小时了。此时，媒体已经嗅到了这个故事的味道。有消息透露，格拉德贝克德意志银行的两名持枪劫匪与警方之间发生了对峙。记者们不知道罪犯的身份，拼命争夺独家新闻。
police at the Glatbeck Deutsche Bank. The journalists didn't know the identity of the criminals and scrambled desperately for a scoop. It was quickly discovered that the police hadn't blocked the bank's phone number so anyone could dial in. A journalist phoned and his call was met by a male voice. When the journalist asked who he was speaking to, the man on the other end of the line replied, the bank robber.
人们很快发现，警方并没有封锁银行的电话号码，因此任何人都可以拨打。一名记者打来电话，他的电话遇到了一个男人的声音。当记者问他在和谁说话时，电话那头的人回答说，银行劫匪。
When asked if they wanted anything other than the money in the car, the robber explained that they also wanted two sets of handcuffs. Realizing that this likely meant the two men had no intention of freeing the bank clerks, the journalist asked, what do you need handcuffs for? That means you are not planning to let the hostages go as soon as the demands are fulfilled. The robber replied, not initially, we want to take them with us. When asked where they planned to go, the robber responded sarcastically, I'm not going to tell you.
当被问及除车里的钱之外是否还想要什么时，劫匪解释说他们还想要两副手铐。意识到这可能意味着这两个人无意释放银行职员，记者问，你们为什么需要手铐？这意味着你们不打算在满足要求后立即放走人质。劫匪回答说，一开始不会，我们想带他们一起走。当被问及他们打算去哪里时，劫匪讽刺地回答说，我才不告诉你们呢。
The journalist warned that they'd be followed wherever they went. The robber replied, conversation is over, then abruptly hung up. A radio station was also able to get through to the bank's phone and conducted an impromptu on-air interview with the robbers, one of them stated, from here on, I only want to speak through the media. Finally, the money was ready. It had been wrapped up in three plastic bundles, a police officer prepared to deliver it. He stripped off his clothes and wore nothing but swimming shorts to prove he was unarmed.
记者警告说，无论他们走到哪里都会被跟踪。劫匪回答说，谈话到此结束，然后生硬地挂断了电话。一家广播电台也打通了银行的电话，并对劫匪进行了现场连线采访，其中一人表示，从现在开始，我只想通过媒体说话。最后，钱准备好了。它们被包裹在三个塑料捆中，一名警官准备送货。他脱下衣服，只穿着泳裤以证明自己没有武装。
Carrying only the bundle of cash, he moved towards the bank. He placed the ransom money by the front entrance. The robbers forced the mail hostage to collect the parcel. Wearing a sling around his neck, the hostage lay sprawled on the floor of the bank's entrance and yanked the glass door open with one hand. One by one, he picked up the parcels of money and threw them to his captors. Then he closed the door and crawled back inside. Multiple police officers continued to monitor the situation as journalists and television
他只带着一捆现金，朝银行走去。他把赎金放在正门旁边。劫匪强迫邮政人质去拿包裹。人质脖子上挂着吊带，四脚朝天地趴在银行入口的地板上，一只手猛地拉开玻璃门。他一包一包地拿起钱包裹，扔给他的绑架者。然后他关上门，爬回里面。随着记者和电视新闻组的旁观，多名警官继续监视着事态发展。
news crews looked on. The hours continued to pass and there was still no sign of the getaway car. Then, at 8pm, a white four-door Audi 100 sedan pulled up outside the bank. When it wasn't parked in the exact way that the robbers had requested, Rosena demanded that it be moved closer to the building. Then he, Dagovsky and the two bank employees emerged from the bank and filed into the car. The intensity of the situation had captured the nation. Cameraman filmed every moment as the police officers looked on.
几个小时过去了，逃跑的车仍然没有踪影。然后，晚上8点，一辆白色的四门奥迪100轿车停在银行外面。当它没有按照劫匪要求的准确方式停放时，罗塞纳要求把它移近大楼。然后他和达戈夫斯基以及两名银行员工从银行里出来，排队上了车。局势的紧张程度吸引了全国的关注。当警官们旁观时，摄影师记录下了每一个时刻。
By now, officers from one of the state's tactical police units known as the SE car had arrived at the scene. With Rosena behind the wheel, the car pulled away at 9.45pm and drove off into the dark night. The police officers had promised they wouldn't follow, but they immediately gave chase. Unbeknown to the bank robbers, a GPS tracking unit had been installed on the Audi, so SE car officers were able to monitor their movements. Their plan was to follow inconspicuously, hoping that the perpetrators would release
此时，被称为SE车的该州战术警察部队的警官已经赶到现场。在罗塞纳的驾驶下，这辆车在晚上9点45分驶离，驶入黑夜。警察们答应不会跟踪，但他们立即展开了追捕。银行劫匪不知道的是，奥迪车上安装了一个GPS追踪装置，因此SE车队的警官能够监控他们的动向。他们的计划是悄悄地跟着，希望罪犯们能释放在途中
their two hostages along the way. Once they were freed, the police officers could run down the felons more safely. They weren't the only ones in hot pursuit. Members of the press received tip-offs from their contacts in the police force and also began chasing after the getaway car in earnest. They were always a step or so behind, often arriving at a location where the car had last been seen just after it departed. Wolfgang Schoenig, the Deutsche Bank's director, was worried.
他们的人质。一旦他们获释，警察就可以更安全地抓捕罪犯。他们并不是唯一一个热切追逐的人。媒体成员从他们在警察局的联系人那里得到了线索，也开始认真追赶逃跑的汽车。他们总是落后一步左右，经常在汽车刚离开后到达最后一次看到汽车的地方。德意志银行行长沃尔夫冈·舍尼格（Wolfgang Schoenig）很担心。
Ever since the robbers had decided they no longer wanted to negotiate with police, he had been acting as their mediator and had spoken to Rosner on the phone numerous times. After receiving the ransom money, Rosner had assured Wolfgang they would be releasing his two employees as soon as it was safe to do so. But now Wolfgang feared that as long as the robbers were being followed, they would refuse to let the hostages go. Wolfgang begged the police to give up their chase, but they refused, assuring him they were following from a safe distance and there was no way that their targets had any idea.
自从劫匪决定不再与警方谈判以来，他一直担任他们的调解员，并多次与罗斯纳通过电话。收到赎金后，罗斯纳向沃尔夫冈保证，只要安全，他们就会释放他的两名员工。但现在沃尔夫冈担心，只要劫匪被跟踪，他们就会拒绝释放人质。沃尔夫冈恳求警方放弃追捕，但遭到拒绝，警方保证他们是在安全距离外跟踪，他们的目标绝无可能知道。
Then at one stage, the bank robbers pulled into a service station. The police were close behind. To their surprise, Rosner walked straight up to an officer and stole his gun. Now he and his accomplice had a total of three firearms. After leaving the bank, Rosner and Dagovsky weren't sure where to turn. They'd made a beeline for the auto barn, a highway system that spanned across the entire country, but they could see that they were being followed by police and the media. For a while, they drove around aimlessly with no destination in mind.
后来在某个阶段，银行劫匪将车开进了一个服务站。警察紧随其后。令他们惊讶的是，罗斯纳径直走向一名警察并抢走了他的枪。现在他和他的同伙总共有三支枪。离开银行后，罗斯纳和达戈夫斯基不知道该去哪里。他们直接奔向贯穿全国的高速公路系统autobahn，但他们可以看到他们正被警察和媒体跟踪漫无目的地开了一会儿，没有目的地。
Suddenly, Rosner was struck with an idea. He would stop by the home of his girlfriend, 34-year-old Marion Lerblik, and pick her up so she could accompany them. After getting in the car, Lerblik suggested that they go to Bremen, a city 238km northeast of Gladbeck, where some of her relatives lived. It was a significant journey that could take up to three hours to complete. Rosner and Dagovsky agreed and got back on the auto barn. As they drove, they turned on the car radio.
突然，罗斯纳心生一计。他决定顺道去他女朋友、34岁的玛丽昂·莱布利克（Marion Lerblik）家，接她一起走。上车后，莱布利克建议他们去不来梅（Bremen），一个位于格拉德贝克东北238公里的城市，她的一些亲戚住在那里。这是一段漫长的旅程，可能需要长达三个小时才能完成。罗斯纳和达戈夫斯基同意了，并回到了高速公路上。开车时，他们打开了汽车收音机。
Stations were providing news updates about their escape and police efforts to track them. After a while, the group stopped at another service station so that everyone could get some food. As Rosner, Dagovsky and Lerblik sat at one table eating, the two hostages sat side by side at another. Undercover officers watched from the very next table. One at a time, Rosner and Dagovsky got up and went to the bathroom. Unwilling to provoke the armed men, the police remained seated and made no attempt to follow
电台一直在提供关于他们逃跑和警方追踪努力的新闻最新消息。过了一会儿，这群人在另一个服务站停下来，以便每个人都能买点食物。当罗斯纳、达戈夫斯基和莱布利克坐在一张桌子旁吃东西时，两名人质并肩坐在另一张桌子旁。便衣警察在隔壁桌旁观察。罗斯纳和达戈夫斯基一个接一个地站起来去洗手间。由于不愿意激怒这些持枪男子，警察仍然坐在座位上，没有试图跟随他们。
them. Eventually, the group got up, piled back into the wide arty, and drove off once again. The police continued to follow the bank robbers as they made their way towards Bremen, but it was members of the media who managed to stay right on their tail. After making several stops along the way, the robbers and their hostages arrived at their destination on the morning of Wednesday, August 17. Still armed, Rosner and his girlfriend Marion Lerblik went shopping, while Dagovsky stayed with the hostages.
最后，这群人站起来，重新挤进那辆宽敞的汽车，再次绝尘而去。警察继续跟踪银行劫匪前往不来梅，但正是媒体成员设法一直尾随其后。在沿途多次停留后，劫匪和他们的人质于8月17日星期三上午抵达目的地。罗斯纳和他的女友玛丽昂·莱布利克仍然带着武器去购物，而达戈夫斯基则留在人质身边。
Rosner purchased a suit and unsuccessfully tried to hire a car in an attempt to switch to a vehicle that law enforcement wouldn't recognize. Back at the car, Dagovsky had consumed a mix of alcohol and pills, and the combination caused him to doze off. Twenty-three-year-old hostage Andrea Blecker noticed that he'd left his gun on a partition between the seats. She and her colleague contemplated snatching the weapon while Dagovsky slept, but were terrified of getting caught.
罗斯纳买了一套西装，并试图租一辆车，但没有成功，试图换成执法部门认不出来的车辆。回到车里，达戈夫斯基服用了一混合酒精和药片的混合物，这种组合导致他打瞌睡。23岁的人质安德烈娅·布莱克注意到他把枪留在了座位之间的隔板上。她和她的同事考虑在达戈夫斯基睡觉时抢走武器，但又害怕被抓。
They decided not to risk it. Rosner returned to the car after an hour and escorted Andrea to a nearby greengrocer. He instructed her to call the police from the store's phone and relay a message on his behalf. The press made no secret of the fact that they were following their every move. A crowd of journalists, photographers and camera crews swarmed around the greengrocer as Andrea picked up the phone and did as she was told. Speaking to a police officer, she complained about law enforcement following them, saying
他们决定不冒这个险。罗斯纳一个小时后回到车里，护送安德烈娅到附近的菜市场。他指示她用店里的电话报警并代表他传达一条信息。媒体毫不掩饰他们正在跟踪他们的一举一动的事实。当安德烈娅拿起电话按吩咐做事时，一大群记者、摄影师和摄像机组蜂拥包围了菜市场。在与一名警察交谈时，她抱怨执法部门跟踪他们，称他们对该团伙的无情追捕是她和她的同事仍然被劫为人质的原因。安德烈娅补充说，他们两个比执法部门更信任绑架者，并警告说如果他们中有人被杀，警察将受到责备。罗斯纳随后从安德烈娅手中抢过电话，要求与特遣部队的高层通话。相关官员当时不在场，罗斯纳的要求没有得到满足。正当罗斯纳试图再次与他们取得联系时，他发现附近有一辆车，他怀疑里面有便衣警察。他勃然大怒，一时冲动抓住了菜市场的一位顾客，也将他们作为人质。随后，他和达戈夫斯基带着人质穿过马路，来到附近的公交车站。新闻工作人员拍摄了他们，他们的动态在全国各地的观众面前进行直播。警察仍然不愿意干预，担心如果他们试图实施逮捕，无辜的人可能会丧生。
that their unrelenting pursuit of the group was the reason she and her colleague were still being held hostage. Andrea added that they both trusted their abductors more than law enforcement and warned that if either of them were killed, the police would be to blame. Rosner then snatched the phone from Andrea and demanded to speak with the task force's top brass. The relevant officers weren't present at the time and Rosner's request was not met. Just as Rosner was attempting to reach out to them again, he spotted a nearby car that
她们认为，执法部门对该团伙的紧追不舍，是她和同事至今仍被扣为人质的原因。安德烈还补充说，她们甚至比信任执法人员更信任绑架者，并警告说如果她们两人中有人遇害，警方将承担全部责任。随后，罗斯纳从安德烈手中抢过电话，要求与专案组的高层领导对话。当时相关警官不在场，罗斯纳的要求未能得到满足。就在罗斯纳试图再次与他们取得联系时，他发现附近有一辆车，
he suspected held undercover officers. He became enraged and impulsively grabbed one of the greengrocers' customers, taking them prisoner as well. He and Dagovsky then marched their hostages across the road to a nearby bus stop. News crews filmed them and their movements were broadcast live to viewers all over the country. Police remained reluctant to intervene, worried that if they attempted to make an arrest, innocent people could end up being killed.
他怀疑车里坐着便衣警察。他勃然大怒，一时冲动抓住了果蔬店的一位顾客，也将其实施绑架。随后，他和达戈夫斯基押解着人质穿过马路，来到附近的一个公交车站。新闻摄制组拍摄了他们的画面，其行踪通过直播传遍了全国观众。警方仍然不愿贸然介入，担心一旦试图实施逮捕，可能会导致无辜平民丧生。
By now, it had been almost 36 hours since Rosner and Dagovsky had set out to rob a bank. The two men were sustaining themselves with amphetamines and pills. They also drank beer constantly. They were growing increasingly desperate to escape and felt a faster getaway car was their only chance to allude those pursuing them. The two men decided they needed a bigger bargaining chip in order to negotiate with the authorities. Idling at the bus stop across the road from the greengrocers was a red public transit bus. Sitting inside was the driver and 25 passengers, ranging from children to the elderly.
此时，距离罗斯纳和达戈夫斯基出发抢劫银行已经过去了近36个小时。这两个人靠安非他命和药丸来维持体力。他们还不断地喝啤酒。他们越来越渴望逃跑，并觉得一辆更快的逃跑汽车是他们摆脱追捕者的唯一机会。这两个人决定他们需要更大的筹码来与当局谈判。在离菜市场马路对面的公交车站闲逛着一辆红色的公共交通巴士。里面坐着司机和25名乘客，从儿童到老人不等。
At approximately 7pm, Rosner and Dagovsky climbed aboard with the two bank hostages and pointed their firearms at the passengers, announcing that they were hijacking the bus. The people on board were confused as to what exactly was going on. Passengers Stephanie Hinspeider thought that they must have been filming a crime show or a program where pranks were played on unsuspecting members of the public. Rosner and Dagovsky had ordered the bank hostages to sit in a pair of seats. One of them sat 18-year-old Ines Voitla and her friend, Silke Bischoff. Ines was confused.
大约晚上7点，罗斯纳和达戈夫斯基带着两名银行人质上了车，用枪指着乘客，宣布他们正在劫持公交车。车上的人对于到底发生了什么感到困惑。乘客斯蒂芬妮·欣斯佩德（Stephanie Hinspeider）认为他们一定是在拍摄犯罪秀或在对毫无戒心的公众成员进行恶作剧的节目。罗斯纳和达戈夫斯基命令银行人质坐在两个座位上。其中一个座位坐着18岁的伊内斯·沃伊特拉（Ines Voitla）和她的朋友西尔克·比肖夫（Silke Bischoff）。伊内斯很困惑。
Like Stephanie, she wondered if the entire thing was part of a low-budget movie. But when she took a closer look at the hostages sitting in front of her, she saw how distraught they looked. After that, she decided to stay quiet and lie low for her own protection. Hostages from Bremen's SE car unit were still reluctant to directly intervene. They'd been ordered to avoid any actions that could place the hostages in danger. According to one responding officer, that pretty much meant that we weren't able to do anything at all.
像斯蒂芬妮一样，她怀疑整件事是否是一部低成本电影的一部分。但当她仔细观察坐在前面的局外人时，她看到他们看起来多么痛苦。在那之后，为了她自己的保护，她决定保持安静，保持低调。来自不来梅SE车队的警察仍然不愿意直接干预。他们被命令避免任何可能将人质置于危险之中的行动。据一名出警的警察说，这基本上意味着我们根本什么也做不了。
In a bizarre twist of fate, the unit had wanted to practice responding to a hostage situation on a bus several weeks earlier. Unfortunately, the drill hadn't gone ahead due to being too expensive to coordinate. While the police stood back and kept a close eye on things, the many journalists who were present descended on the bus stop. For them, the chance to cover a crime in real time with no interference from police was an incredible once-in-a-lifetime opportunity. Tegovsky stayed on the bus, but Rosena disembarked, seeming to relish the media attention.
命运的一个诡异转折是，该部队几周前曾想练习应对公共汽车上的劫持人质情况。不幸的是，由于协调成本太高，演习没有进行。在警察退后并密切关注事情的同时，在场的许多记者蜂拥至公交车站。对他们来说，有机会在没有警察干涉的情况下实时报道犯罪是一次千载难逢的绝佳机会。特戈夫斯基留在车上，但罗塞纳下车了，似乎很享受媒体的关注。
Journalists thrust microphones and cameras at his face. The startling update was broadcast to viewers at home. Camera crews and photographers boarded the bus to get close-up angles of the situation on board. Journalists watched on as the media documented their ordeal, but made no attempt to assist them. Tegovsky posed for the cameras with a smirk on his face as he casually held his pistol in one hand.
记者们将麦克风和摄像机怼到他脸上。这一令人震惊的更新被广播给家里的观众。摄像机组和摄影师登上了公交车，以获得车内情况的特写镜头。记者们看着媒体记录他们的磨难，但没有试图协助他们。特戈夫斯基带着得意的微笑对着镜头摆姿势，同时随手用一只手拿着手枪。
Rosena's girlfriend, Marion Lerblik, was carrying the third firearm. In their frenzy to be the first to break the story, some journalists mistakenly claimed that a police officer was among the now 28 hostages. Bremen's mayor, Klaus Wiedermeister, had arrived at the increasingly chaotic scene and appeared on camera. He criticized the media's coverage of the dangerous situation, stating, I think you've crossed a line. As soon as his interview concluded, reporters returned their attention to the bank robbers.
罗塞纳的女友玛丽昂·莱布利克（Marion Lerblik）带着第三支枪。在争当第一个打破新闻的狂热中，一些记者错误地声称一名警察在现在28名人质之中。不来梅市长克劳斯·维德迈斯特（Klaus Wiedermeister）已经赶到日益混乱的现场，并在镜头前露面。他对媒体对危险局势的报道进行了批评，并表示，我认为你们越界了。他的采访一结束，记者们就把注意力转向了银行劫匪。
Rosena gave an impromptu press conference just outside the bus. He held a pistol in his right hand as he spoke to reporters. When asked why he had decided to rob the bank in the first place, he simply replied, I don't have any morals, there is no other work for me, I want to live my life. His face was blank as he said, my buddy is very dangerous, this will be the end, I already sat 13 years in prison, I don't give a shit for my whole life. Then he mimed suicide by placing the nozzle of the gun in his mouth. About 15 minutes after the bus was hijacked, some of the passengers had had enough.
罗塞纳在公交车外进行了即兴新闻发布会。他右手拿着手枪对记者讲话。当被问及为什么一开始决定抢劫银行时，他简单地回答说，我没有任何道德，没有别的工作可做，我想过我的人生。当他说“我的哥们很危险，这将是结局，我已经坐了13年牢了，我对我的整个人生毫不在乎”时，他的脸上没有任何表情。然后他把枪口塞进嘴里，模仿自杀。在公交车被劫持大约15分钟后，一些乘客已经受够了。
They weren't sure what was happening, but the presence of the media gave the situation a surreal feel. There was little sense of fear, even though they'd been threatened with guns. Four elderly passengers and one child disembarked the vehicle, with one woman pausing to ask some journalists if she was allowed to do so. They gave her permission and she continued on her way. Neither Rosna nor Degofsky tried to stop any of them from leaving. One of the elderly passengers later told the press, I simply stood up, no one stopped me.
他们不确定发生了什么，但媒体的存在给局势带来了一种超现实的感觉。虽然他们受到了枪支的威胁，但恐惧感却微乎其微。四名年长的乘客和一个小孩下了车，其中一名女性停下来问一些记者她是否可以这样做。他们批准了她的请求，她继续上路了。罗塞纳和德戈夫斯基都没有试图阻止他们中的任何人离开。其中一位老乘客后来告诉媒体，我只是站起来，没有人阻止我。
Live footage of the ongoing crisis was streamed throughout evening news programs. The entire country was captivated. A press photographer named Peter Meyer took on the role of messenger, acting as a go-between between the bank robbers and the police. Rosna was now asking for a faster car free from tracking devices, another 300,000 to 400,000 marks, an extra set of handcuffs, and a police officer whose hands were bound. In exchange for these things, he and Degofsky would release all of the hostages on the bus. If their demands were not met, Rosna said they would blow up the bus.
对正在进行的危机的现场直播在晚间新闻节目中播出。整个全国都为之着迷。一位名叫彼得·迈耶（Peter Meyer）的摄影记者扮演了信使的角色，充当银行劫匪和警察之间的中间人。罗塞纳现在要求一辆没有追踪装置的更快汽车、另外30万到40万马克、另一套手铐以及一名双手被绑的警察。作为交换，他和德戈夫斯基将释放公交车上的所有人质。如果他们的要求得不到满足，罗塞纳说他们会炸毁公交车。
The photographer shared these demands with the press before passing them on to police. Officers watched from a safe distance. They were reluctant to provide one of their own as a hostage, given the perpetrator's obvious dislike of law enforcement. By this time, snipers had been dispatched to the scene and were hiding nearby with a perfect view of the bus stop. They were just waiting for the right moment to strike and the permission to do so. It was never granted.
摄影师在将这些要求转交给警方之前，先与媒体分享了这些要求。警察在安全距离外观察。考虑到嫌疑人对执法部门的明显厌恶，他们不愿意提供自己人作为人质。此时，狙击手已被派往现场，并隐蔽在附近，对公交车站有一览无余的视野。他们只是在等待合适的时机和这样做的许可。这从未被批准。
Although the bank robbers were often in their sights while the hostages remained safely on the bus, a local law prevented so-called rescue shooting. Rosna continued chatting with the media, who occasionally lit cigarettes for him. He appeared relaxed and seemed to enjoy his sudden celebrity status. At one stage, he left his pistol lying across his lap as he spoke to reporters. But eventually, he got tired of relaying his demands via a messenger and demanded that the police speak to him directly. Peter Meyer begged some officers to do so, but they refused.
虽然银行劫匪经常出现在他们的视线中，而人质安全地留在公交车上，但当地的一项法律阻止了所谓的救援射击。罗塞纳继续与媒体闲聊，媒体偶尔会为他点烟。他显得很放松，似乎很享受他突然的名人地位。有一次，他在与记者交谈时将手枪放在膝盖上。但最终，他厌倦了通过信使传达他的要求，并要求警察直接与他对话。彼得·迈耶恳求一些警察这样做，但他们拒绝了。
Instead, they gave him a radio that Rosna could use to speak to them. Rosna tried to use the radio, but it didn't work. He became infuriated and his rage only increased when he spotted what he thought was a police officer in the window of a nearby building. Rosna stormed onto the bus and grabbed one of the hostages, 18-year-old Silke Bischoff. Silke was a court stenographer and a trainee at a law firm situated in Bremen. She'd finished work an hour early that day, but had waited for her friend and colleague Ines Voetler to finish so they could catch the bus home together.
相反，他们给了他一个罗塞纳可以用来与他们交谈的对讲机。罗塞纳试图使用对讲机，但它坏了。他勃然大怒，当他发现附近一栋大楼的窗户里有一个他认为是警察的人时，他的愤怒更是火上浇油。罗塞纳冲上公交车，抓住了其中一名人质，18岁的西尔克·比肖夫。西尔克是不来梅一家律师事务所的法庭速记员和实习生。她那天提前一个小时完成了工作，但一直在等她的朋友兼同事伊内斯·沃特勒（Ines Voetler）完成工作，以便他们可以一起坐公交车回家。
Rosna pulled Silke off the bus, then dragged her in front of the police and media as he pressed his gun to her head and shouted, You motherfucker, fuck off or it is going to fire up in here. Rosna then shot in the direction of the window and added, This is the last warning, the next one is going to fly out of the bus. The commotion drew more onlookers to the scene. By now daylight was fading and it was growing dark. Rosna continued trying to use the police radio, but it had very poor reception.
罗塞纳把西尔克拉下公交车，然后把她拉到警察和媒体面前，同时把枪顶在她头上并喊道，你们这些杂种，滚开，否则这里就要开火了。罗塞纳随后朝着窗户的方向开枪，并补充道，这是最后一次警告，下一个就要飞出公交车了。这起骚乱吸引了更多的旁观者来到现场。此时天色渐暗，天黑了。罗塞纳继续试图使用警察对讲机，但信号很差。
The demands he barked into it were going ignored. Frustrated by the lack of response from police, Rosna grabbed another hostage. This time he chose an 8-year-old girl named Tatiana DeGiorgi who had been riding the bus with her 15-year-old brother Emanuella. Their family was Italian and had migrated to West Germany in the hopes of a better, more prosperous life. Rosna used Tatiana as a protective shield, holding the gun to her head as he screamed, What is going on now, you motherfucker, you cowardly pigs.
他对着它大喊的要求被忽视了。由于对警察缺乏反应感到沮丧，罗塞纳抓住了另一个人质。这次他选择了一个8岁的小女孩，名叫塔蒂亚娜·德焦尔吉（Tatiana DeGiorgi），她一直和她15岁的哥哥埃马努埃拉（Emanuella）一起坐公交车。他们的家庭是意大利人，为了更好、更繁荣的生活移民到了西德。罗塞纳把塔蒂亚娜当成保护盾，把枪顶在她头上尖叫道，现在是怎么回事，你们这些混蛋，这些懦弱的猪。
The only other sound aside from his voice was the click of cameras as photographers snapped shots of the disturbing scene. News crews captured Tatiana standing there, dressed in a dark colored skirt, a striped long-sleeved top and a white headband in her long dark hair. She looked frightened as she clutched a red bag to her chest. Rosna handed the police radio to Peter Meyer and gave him a new message to pass on. He wanted a new radio and would drive the bus around the block until it was ready. Peter ran back to the police to update them.
除了他的声音之外，唯一的其他声音是摄影师拍摄这个令人不安的场景时快门的咔哒声。新闻摄制组拍摄了塔蒂亚娜站在那里的情景，她穿着深色裙子、条纹长袖上衣和一根白色发箍在长长的黑发中。她紧紧抓着一个红色的包，看起来很害怕。罗塞纳把警察对讲机交给了彼得·迈耶，并给他留了一条新信息。他想要一个新的对讲机，并将在准备好之前驾驶公交车绕街区转。彼得跑回警察那里向他们汇报最新情况。
He explained that he'd tried to convince Rosna to leave the hostages and use his car instead, but he declined. At 10pm, Rosna and DeGovsky had finally had enough of waiting. They took command of the bus and it pulled away from the small shopping strip. An investigator later reflected. It was pretty much the turning point with no peaceful ending to hope for. Peter Meyer decided to get in his car and follow them. As he had a car phone, he dialed a number some officers had given him that was supposed
他解释说，他曾试图说服罗塞纳离开人质并改用他的车，但他拒绝了。晚上10点，罗塞纳和德戈夫斯基终于受够了等待。他们接管了公交车，公交车驶离了小型购物带。一位调查人员后来反思道。这几乎是一个转折点，没有和平结局的希望。彼得·迈耶决定上车跟随他们。由于他有车载电话，他拨打了一些警官给他的号码，据信该号码
to connect him with the case's operation controllers. The call failed to go through. Peter wasn't sure whether the police had made a mistake when giving him the number, if they deliberately provided the wrong one. The bus steered back on the autobahn and began heading northeast. Tatiana DeGeorgi sat on the lap of her older brother, Emanuella. He did his best to keep her calm by whispering assurances, telling her, Don't be scared, I'll protect you.
将他与案件的操作控制人员联系起来。电话打不通。彼得不确定警察在给他号码时是否犯了错误，还是他们故意提供了错误的号码。公交车重新驶上高速公路，开始向东北方向行驶。塔蒂亚娜·德焦尔吉坐在她哥哥埃马努埃拉的膝盖上。他尽最大努力通过低声安慰来让她平静下来，告诉她，别害怕，我会保护你的。
After travelling almost 40km, the bank robbers pulled over at a highway service station. Marion Lerblik needed to use the bathroom and Rosna and DeGovsky decided it would be a good idea to also buy some food and alcohol. The journalists pursuing the vehicle quickly realised what was going on and stopped at the rest stop as well. While Lerblik made her way to the bathroom, DeGovsky disembarked the bus for the first time since he and his accomplice had commandeered it. To protect himself, he took hostage Silke Bischoff with him, holding a gun to her throat.
行驶了近40公里后，银行劫匪在一个高速公路服务区停了下来。玛丽昂·莱布利克需要上洗手间，罗斯纳和德戈夫斯基觉得顺便买点食物和酒精是个好主意。追逐该车的记者很快意识到发生了什么，也在休息站停了下来。当莱布利克去洗手间时，自他和同伙劫持公交车以来，德戈夫斯基第一次下车。为了保护自己，他带着人质西尔克·比肖夫下车，用枪抵着她的喉咙。
If Silke feared for her life, she refused to show it. She remained stoic as reporters gathered around her and DeGovsky and pointed microphones at her armed captor while peppering him with questions. When one journalist asked if he was really willing to kill people, DeGovsky simply replied, Yes. Silke was interviewed as well. When a reporter asked how she felt, she responded, Actually pretty good considering the circumstances, I don't really get it.
如果西尔克为自己的生命感到害怕，她拒绝表现出来。当记者聚集在她和德戈夫斯基周围，将麦克风对准她武装的绑架者并向他抛出一连串问题时，她表现得泰然自若。当一名记者问他是否真的愿意杀人时，德戈夫斯基只是简单地回答，是的。西尔克也接受了采访。当记者问她感觉如何时，她回答说，考虑到目前的情况，其实挺好的，我真的不明白。
She couldn't imagine that DeGovsky would really shoot her, despite his constant threats. They seemed empty and hollow. He'd had his chance to harm others, but had opted to avoid a bloodshed and, in some cases, let hostages go. A journalist even interviewed press photographer Peter Meier, who had inadvertently become a part of the story since acting as the robber's messenger. Peter was concerned that police were not handling the situation well. First, they'd refused to send an officer in to communicate with the two culprits.
尽管他不断威胁，她无法想象德戈夫斯基真的会向她开枪。它们似乎是空洞的。他曾有机会伤害他人，但最终选择避免流血，并在某些情况下释放人质。一名记者甚至采访了摄影师彼得·迈尔，他由于充当劫匪的信使而无意中成为了这个故事的一部分。彼得担心警察没有很好地处理局势。首先，他们拒绝派一名警察进去与两个罪犯沟通。
Then they'd provided radios that didn't work well, and a phone number that failed to connect. I really don't know what the police are thinking, Peter worried aloud. Peter was also anxious about the two bank employees who'd been held captive since the previous morning, more than 38 hours earlier. The length of their ordeal meant they were battling stress and exhaustion. He convinced Rosna and DeGovsky to release them in exchange for him and a colleague taking their place. Both employees looked extremely relieved as they were freed from the bus and permitted
然后他们提供了不好用的对讲机，和一个无法接通的电话号码。彼得大声担忧道，我真的不知道警察在想什么。彼得还对自前天早上以来被扣为人质、已经超过38个小时的两名银行员工感到焦虑。他们磨难的时间意味着他们正在与压力和疲劳作斗争。他游说罗斯纳和德戈夫斯基释放他们，以此换取他和一位同事取代他们的位置。两名员工在被从公交车上释放并允许离开时，看起来都极其如释重负。
to leave. Andrea Blecker later told the media that she'd kept hoping she would be let go, but had resigned herself to the possibility of being shot instead. Journalists weren't the only observers who'd gathered at the scene. Some police officers had arrived, too, and were debating whether or not to finally act. Hans Jürgen Rosner's girlfriend, Marianne Lerblik, had walked from the bus to a public rest room. She'd taken a female hostage with her and had made sure to carry her gun.
安德烈娅·布莱克后来告诉媒体，她一直希望自己能被放走，但同时也做好了被枪杀的心理准备。记者并不是聚集在现场的唯一观察者。一些警察也赶到了，正在争论是否终于要采取行动。汉斯·于尔根·罗斯纳的女友玛丽安娜·莱布利克（Marianne Lerblik）已经从公交车走到公共洗手间。她带了一名人质去，并确保带上了她的枪。
Two policemen thought they could overpower her. They hadn't sought or received permission from their higher-ups to attempt an arrest, but the opportunity seemed too good to resist. Another officer confirmed that they should go ahead with the spontaneous plan, telling his colleagues, if it is possible, get her. Four officers stood outside the bathroom and waited. When they saw Lerblik walk out, they pounced. Two policemen grappled with her.
两名警察认为他们可以制服她。他们没有寻求也没有得到上级试图逮捕的许可，但这个机会似乎太诱人了，无法抗拒。另一名官证实他们应该继续这个突发计划，并告诉他的同事，如果可能的话，抓住她。四名警察站在洗手间外面等待。当他们看到莱布利克走出来时，他们扑了上去。两名警察与她扭打在一起。
As she started to scream, one placed his hand over her mouth to muffle her cries. They successfully wrestled Lerblik to the ground and removed her weapon before slapping handcuffs on her wrists. Now they had one of the three wanted individuals in their custody. But some were baffled by their decision. A reporter later asked the question, why would you catch the most harmless person out of the three while the other two idiots remained armed in the bus with the hostages? Meanwhile, Rosna and Degovsky were waiting for Lerblik to return.
当她开始尖叫时，一个人把手捂在她的嘴上以压制她的哭声。他们成功地将莱布利克摔倒在地，移除了她的武器，然后把手铐戴在她的手腕上。现在他们拘留了三个通缉犯中的一个。但有些人对他们的决定感到困惑。一名记者后来提出了一个问题，为什么要在另外两个白痴带着人质在公交车上保持武装的同时，去抓三个人中最无害的人呢？与此同时，罗塞纳和德戈夫斯基在等莱布利克回来。
Minutes ticked by, and still there was no sign of her. A visit to the bathroom shouldn't have taken this long. Then Rosna heard what sounded like his girlfriend screaming. Adorned on the two bank robbers that she must have been apprehended. Rosna was furious. He began ranting. They shouldn't have done this, these pigs, these goddamn pigs, these bastards. Speaking through photographer Peter Meyer, he issued an ultimatum.
分钟一分一秒地过去，依然没有她的踪影。上洗手间不应该花这么长时间。然后罗塞纳听到疑似他女友尖叫的声音。两个银行劫匪意识到她一定被捕了。罗塞纳勃然大怒。他开始喋喋不休地怒骂。他们不该这么做，这些猪，这些该死的猪，这些混蛋。通过摄影师彼得·迈尔传话，他发出了最后通牒。
Return his girlfriend in five minutes, or he would shoot a hostage. A fierce debate ensued between the police officers present. Not wanting to risk the lives of the hostages, one policeman insisted that Lerblik be released and sent back to her accomplices. But the two who'd arrested her were reluctant to send her back. After some back and forth, they eventually agreed that they couldn't ignore Rosna's demands. One was running out, and the risk was too great.
在五分钟内归还他的女友，否则他将射杀一个人质。在场的警察之间爆发了激烈的争论。为了不冒人质生命的危险，一名警察坚持释放莱布利克并将其送回她的同伙身边。但逮捕她的两名警察不愿放她回去。在经过一番反复交涉后，他们最终同意他们无法忽视罗斯纳的要求。时间快用完了，风险太大了。
The key to Lerblik's handcuffs was fetched, and the police prepared to let her go. Just as one of the officers went to turn the key, it snapped and broke off inside the lock. Now broken, the key was useless, and the handcuffs couldn't be removed. The police would have to find another way to remove them, but the five minutes Rosna had allotted were almost up. Peter Meyer was quickly sent over to the bus to alert the bank robbers that Lerblik was on her way. Meanwhile, the police scrambled to remove her handcuffs.
莱布利克手铐的钥匙被拿来了，警察准备放她走。正当其中一名警察去转动钥匙时，钥匙在锁里啪地一声断了。现在断了的钥匙没用了，手铐也解不开了。警察必须找到另一种方法来取下它们，但罗斯纳规定的五分钟快到了。彼得·迈尔被迅速派往公交车，提醒银行劫匪莱布利克正在路上。与此同时，警察手忙脚乱地试图取下手铐。
Back on the bus, tensions were mounting. Five minutes had passed since Rosna demanded the return of his girlfriend. Peter Meyer had shared the police message that Lerblik would be coming back soon, but there was no sign of her. In a rage, Rosna turned to eight-year-old hostage Tatiana de Georgie, grabbed her arm, and dragged her away from her brother. He pointed his gun at her head. Manuela rushed over and tried to pull his younger sister to safety.
回到大巴上，紧张气氛不断升级。距离罗斯纳要求归还女友已经过去五分钟。彼得·迈尔传达了警方关于勒布利克很快就会回来的消息，但仍不见她的踪影。罗斯纳勃然大怒，转向八岁的人质塔蒂亚娜·德·乔治，抓起她的胳膊把她从她哥哥身边拖开。他把枪对准了她的头。曼努埃拉冲过去，试图把年幼的妹妹拉到安全地带。
Dieter Degofsky turned around to face the two siblings and aimed his gun. Then, he pulled the trigger and fired three times. All of the hostages began screaming. Tatiana saw her brother crumple in front of her and fall to the floor. He had been shot in the head. One minute later, Marion Lerblik boarded the bus, having been released by the police officers. Having shot a hostage, Rosna and Degofsky were once again eager to hit the road. With Lerblik returned to them, there was nothing left to wait for.
迪特尔·德戈夫斯基转身面对这两兄妹并举枪瞄准。随后，他扣动扳机连开三枪。所有人质开始尖叫。塔蒂亚娜眼睁睁看着哥哥在自己面前瘫软并倒在地板上。他的头部中枪。一分钟后，在警察的释放下，马里昂·勒布利克登上了大巴。由于枪击了人质，罗斯纳和德戈夫斯基再次急于上路。既然勒布利克已经回到他们身边，也就没什么好等待的了。
The two men pulled Manuela de Georgie's body from the bus and dumped it at the highway rest stop, before speeding away from the scene with their hostages. The journalists who were covering the unfolding story found Manuela's body. He was clad in denim jeans and a white t-shirt soaked in blood. He looked lifeless, but a check of his vital signs revealed he was still alive, despite sustaining three shots to the head. Two press photographers dragged his body to safety. News crews filmed them doing so, broadcasting live footage of the wounded and unconscious
两名男子将曼努埃拉·德·乔治的尸体从大巴上拖下来，扔在高速公路休息区，随后带着人质加速逃离现场。报道这起持续事件的记者们发现了曼努埃拉的尸体。他穿着牛仔裤和一件被血浸透的白色T恤。他看起来毫无生气，但检查生命体征发现，尽管头部中了三枪，他居然还活着。两名新闻摄影师将他的尸体拖到安全地带。新闻摄制组拍摄了这一过程，向全国直播了这位受伤且失去知觉的
15-year-old across the country. One of the photographers held up Manuela's head so that the crew could get a better angle of his face. At the service station, an attendant phoned for an ambulance. It took 20 minutes to arrive. During the wait, Manuela bled to death. Along with 24 other hostages, his little sister was still on board the bus with the men who killed him.
15岁少年的画面。其中一名摄影师托起曼努埃拉的头部，以便摄制组能从更好的角度拍摄他的面部。在服务区，一名服务员打电话叫了救护车。救护车花了20分钟才赶到。在等待期间，曼努埃拉因流血过多而死亡。连同其他24名人质一起，他的小妹妹当时仍然和杀死他的歹徒们一起在大巴上。
The bus careened along the autobahn as the bank robbers headed south-west. Rosner had decided they should leave northwest Germany and make their way to the border with the Netherlands. He'd heard that police in the neighbouring country were friendlier than those in west Germany and hoped that they might go easier on them. Some journalists were still enthusiastically pursuing them, following the bus in their cars and taxis. Driving in vehicles behind the media were numerous police officers.
随着劫匪向西南方向驶去，大巴在高速公路上疾驰。罗斯纳决定离开德国西北部，前往荷兰边境。他听说邻国的警察比西德警察更友善，并希望他们能对他们网开一面。一些记者仍然热情地穷追不舍，用汽车和出租车紧追大巴。在媒体车辆后面行驶的是大量警察。
To their frustration, they couldn't get close to the bus due to the row of cars in front. At one stage, as many as four press vehicles were driving side-by-side along the autobahn, making it impossible for the police to overtake them. Despite the fact that law enforcement was prevented from reaching the bus, Rosner and Dagovsky made their hostages stand throughout the journey, just in case the police decided to shoot through the windows. At one point, a taxi carrying a journalist veered slightly too close to the bus.
令他们沮丧的是，由于前方排成一列的汽车，他们无法靠近大巴。在某个阶段，多达四辆媒体车辆并排行驶在高速公路上，导致警察根本无法超车。尽管执法人员无法接近大巴，但罗斯纳和达戈夫斯基仍强迫人质在整个行程中站立，以防警察决定隔窗开枪。一度，一辆载有记者的出租车离大巴太近了。
This enraged Rosner. He aimed his gun and fired through a window, shattering the glass. Western police officers attempted to overtake the reporters and hone in on the bus. They collided with a truck. One policeman was killed and two others were injured in the collision. West German police had caught on to the bank robbers' plan to flee to the Netherlands and notified customs officials who closed the border. While the bus would be permitted to cross, the journalists following it would not.
这激怒了罗斯纳。他举枪隔着车窗开火，玻璃应声碎裂。西德警察试图超越记者并逼近大巴。他们与一辆卡车相撞。一名警察在碰撞中身亡，另有两名警察受伤。西德警察已经识破了劫匪逃往荷兰的计划，并通知了海关官员，后者关闭了边境。虽然大巴将被允许通行，但尾随其后的记者则不行。
At about 2.30am on Thursday, August 18, the bus reached the border. The two bank robbers crossed over into the Netherlands and parked the bus in a remote forest near the town of Oldenzaal. Dutch police officers were waiting for them. They quickly informed Rosner and Degofsky that they would not enter into any negotiations with them as long as they were holding children hostage. A standoff ensued. After almost three hours, the two bank robbers finally agreed to release the children.
8月18日星期四凌晨2点30分左右，大巴抵达边境。两名劫匪越境进入荷兰，并将大巴停在奥尔登扎尔镇附近的一个偏僻森林里。荷兰警察正等着他们。他们迅速通知罗斯纳和德戈夫斯基，只要他们劫持儿童为人质，他们就不会与他们进行任何谈判。对峙随之展开。将近三个小时后，两名劫匪终于同意释放儿童。
At 5.15am, three children, including Tatiana de Georgie and two women, were allowed to disembark the bus. Now, the Dutch police were willing to negotiate. Rosner and Degofsky wanted a new vehicle, a high-powered BMW. If they received that, then they would free even more hostages. German police said about preparing a dark grey BMW 735i. Unbeknownst to the bank robbers, they arranged it so that the vehicle's engine could be stopped via a remote control in their possession.
凌晨5点15分，包括塔蒂亚娜·德·乔治在内的三名儿童和两名妇女被允许下车。此时，荷兰警察愿意谈判了。罗斯纳和德戈夫斯基想要一辆新车，一辆高性能的宝马。如果他们得到这辆车，他们就会释放更多人质。德国警察假装准备一辆深灰色宝马735i。劫匪们并不知道，他们做了安排，可以通过他们自己拥有的一個遥控器来切断这辆车的发动机。
Although customs officials had closed the border, some journalists had been able to sneak across via back roads and alternate routes. Hundreds of German and Dutch reporters had descended on the scene to report live and snap more photographs of the ongoing crisis. Dutch police were keeping a close eye on the bus and had orders to apprehend if the perpetrators attempted violence. Then, Rosner's gun accidentally went off and a lerblich was hit in the leg. Thinking he was purposely shooting, officers started firing back.
尽管海关官员关闭了边境，但一些记者还是通过小路和替代路线偷偷溜了过来。数百名德国和荷兰记者蜂拥至现场进行现场报道，并拍摄了这场仍在持续的危机的更多照片。荷兰警察一直在密切监视大巴，并奉命一旦行凶者试图使用暴力就将其逮捕。就在这时，罗斯纳的枪走火了，勒布利克腿部中弹。误以为对方是故意开枪，警员们开始开枪还击。
Police flung themselves to the floor as bullets rained on the bus. Rosner began screaming into the police radio he'd been given. That was not against you, had happened accidentally. Eventually, police ceased fire and the air fell silent. The bus was now riddled with bullets. Due to the damage and the fact they were getting a new getaway car, Rosner and Dagovsky agreed to free almost all of their 20 remaining hostages. However, they still wanted to hold on to two of them as a precaution.
随着子弹如雨点般落在大巴上，警察纷纷扑倒在地。罗斯纳对着给他的警用对讲机大喊。那不是针对你们的，是不小心走火的。最终，警察停火，空气陷入死寂。大巴此时已布满弹孔。由于车辆受损以及他们将获得一辆新的逃跑车辆，罗斯纳和达戈夫斯基同意释放剩下的近20名人质中的大部分。然而，出于谨慎起见，他们仍想扣留其中两人。
They selected 18-year-old Franz, Silke Bischoff and Enos Voetler. At 6.30am, the BMW was delivered. The men forced Silke and Enos inside, along with Marion Lerblich. Then they sped off once again. Initially, they headed west towards Amsterdam, the capital of the Netherlands, with Dutch investigators in hot pursuit. But then they suddenly turned and began making their way back towards west Germany. Just after 7am, they crossed over the German border.
他们挑选了18岁的弗兰茨、西尔克·比肖夫和埃诺斯·福特勒。早上6点30分，宝马车送到了。这群人强行将西尔克和埃诺斯塞进车里，还有马里昂·勒布利克。然后他们再次疾驰而去。起初，他们在荷兰首都阿姆斯特丹西面疾驰，荷兰调查人员紧追不舍。但随后他们突然转向，开始返回西德。刚过早上7点，他们就越过了德国边境。
They raced through the state of North Rhine-Westfalia until they reached the city of Cologne. Cologne is the fourth most popular city in Germany. Due to heavy bombing during World War II, it required significant reconstruction during the post-war years through to the late 20th century. By the end of the 1980s, the rebuilding of Cologne's most famous landmarks was almost complete. When the bank robbers and their hostages reached the city, it was mid-morning on Thursday, August 18.
他们穿过北莱茵-威斯特法伦州，直到抵达科隆市。科隆是德国第四大城市。由于二战期间遭受猛烈轰炸，它在战后到20世纪后期经历了大规模重建。到20世纪80年代末，科隆最著名地标的重建工作已接近尾声。当劫匪和人质抵达该市时，时间是8月18日星期四上午。
Once again, they had been followed by an entourage of journalists and police. As soon as they parked their car in a popular shopping district at the city's centre, they were surrounded by reporters. Curious onlookers who'd heard reports that the country's most wanted felons had arrived in town also congregated in the area to catch a glimpse. The hostage situation and associated media circus made for a strange sight on the busy city streets. Pedestrians were bustling about, and nearby, a folk band was busking.
他们再次遭到记者和警察随行人员的尾随。一将车停在市中心一个热闹的购物区，他们就被记者团团包围。听到全国最通缉的罪犯抵达该镇的传言而好奇的旁观者也聚集在该地区一探究竟。人质事件和随之而来的媒体狂欢在繁忙的城市街道上构成了一幅奇特的景象。行人生气勃勃地匆匆走过，不远处，一支民间乐队正在卖艺。
Rosner got out of the car and walked to a nearby bakery where he purchased some bread rolls. Then he headed back to the BMW and sat behind the wheel next to his girlfriend. Dozens and dozens of journalists had swarmed around the BMW, some leaning across its bonnet and pressing against its sides. The air inside the car grew stuffy as bodies crowded around it. Microphones and cameras were shoved through the open windows. The journalists surrounding the car inadvertently provided a protective barrier and made it impossible
罗斯纳下车走到附近的一家面包店买了一些面包卷。然后他回到宝马车上，坐在女友旁边的驾驶座上。数十名记者蜂拥围住宝马车，一些人趴在引擎盖上，紧贴着车身。随着人群聚集，车内空气变得闷热。麦克风和摄像机从打开的车窗伸进来。包围汽车的记者无意中构筑了一道保护屏障，使得
for police to approach. Dagowski remained in the back of the vehicle, wedged between silka and enus, while chain smoking cigarettes and casually holding a pistol in his right hand. Occasionally he used a pair of binoculars to peer out the rear window, keeping his eyes peeled for police. When a reporter asked Rosner what they were doing in the city, silka sarcastically quipped from the back seat, visiting the Cathedral of Cologne. Rosner explained that they had been thwarted at every turn by German police refusing to
警察无法靠近。达戈夫斯基留在车后座，夹在西尔克和埃诺斯之间，同时连轴抽烟，右手随意地拿着一把手枪。他偶尔用一副双筒望远镜透过后车窗向外张望，密切注意警察的动向。当一名记者问罗斯纳他们在城里做什么时，西尔克从后座讽刺地打趣道：“参观科隆大教堂。”罗斯纳解释说，德国警察拒绝谈判，导致他们处处受阻。
negotiate. Marion Lerblik expressed her regret that Emanuella de Georgie had been killed, but blamed law enforcement for detaining her instead of the two men. She insisted that they were looking after silka and enus, adding, We are not harming them, and we don't want to harm them. Rosner was aware that he and Dagowski would be facing enormous ramifications for murdering Emanuella. He expressed his frustration at the now two-day ordeal, but said that if the police tried
马里昂·勒布利克对埃曼纽拉·德·乔治被杀表示遗憾，但指责执法人员扣留了她而不是那两个男人。她坚称他们一直在照顾西尔克和埃诺斯，并补充说：“我们没有伤害他们，我们也不想伤害他们。”罗斯纳意识到他和达戈夫斯基将因谋杀埃曼纽拉而面临巨大的后果。他对这场已经持续两天的磨难表达了沮丧，但表示如果警察试图
to arrest them, they would kill both hostages, then take their own lives. He placed the barrel of the gun in his mouth to prove how serious he was. Dagowski agreed with his accomplice, stating, We aren't going to negotiate with police anymore, because we know that leads to nothing. I want to say through the news media that the police should back off. As he chatted with the journalists, he nonchalantly pressed his gun to silka's neck and head. At one point, a reporter complained that he hadn't gotten the picture he wanted and demanded, Hold the gun to her temple again, I don't have a photograph yet.
逮捕他们，他们就会杀死两个人质，然后自杀。他把枪管含在嘴里以证明自己是认真的。达戈夫斯基同意同伙的说法，并表示：“我们不会再与警察谈判了，因为我们知道那毫无结果。我想通过新闻媒体说，警察应该退后。”在与记者闲聊时，他漫不经心地将枪顶在西尔克的脖子和头上。一度，一名记者抱怨说没有拍到想要的画面并要求道：“把枪再顶到她太阳穴上，我还没拍到照片呢。”
Silka still looked calm, and occasionally even managed to give a small smile. Only her wide eyes occasionally betrayed a hint of alarm. When a reporter asked Silka how she was holding up, she said she was fine. However, she was worried that the police would ignore the bank robbers' demands, which could lead to another person being killed. She pleaded, Just do what they request and don't try to interfere, I'm scared of that. The two bank robbers gave interview after interview. Reporters helped them by supplying cups of coffee and attempting to negotiate on their
西尔克看起来仍然很冷静，偶尔甚至设法露出一个微笑。只有她睁大的眼睛偶尔泄露出一丝惊恐。当记者问西尔克她情况如何时，她说她很好。然而，她担心警察会忽视劫匪的要求，这可能会导致另一个人丧生。她恳求道：“照他们要求的做，别去干涉，我很害怕那样。”这两名劫匪接连接受采访。记者们通过提供咖啡杯并试图代表他们进行
behalf, suggesting they trade their hostages for police officers. When plain clothes officers were sent over in the hopes they might be able to get closer than their uniformed counterparts, some journalists pointed them out to the bank robbers. Rosna was queried as to what would happen if the police attempted anything. He simply answered, Then there's going to be a blood bath here. Earlier that morning, Udu Raubel, the deputy editor of the Cologne Daily Express, had headed to his local tennis club for a friendly game. He'd taken some time off from work and hadn't watched television or listened to the radio
谈判来协助他们，建议他们用人质交换警察。当便衣警察被派过去，希望能比穿制服的同行靠得更近时，一些记者向劫匪指出了他们。罗斯纳被问及如果警察采取行动会发生什么。他简单地回答：“那这里就会血流成河。”当天早些时候，《科隆每日快报》副总编辑乌杜·劳贝尔前往他当地的网球俱乐部进行一场友谊赛。他休假了一段时间，已经有一两天没看电视或听广播了。
for a couple of days. As Raubel headed into the club's cafeteria, his attention was drawn to a TV set showing the morning news. For the first time, he learned of the events that had gripped west to Germany over the past two days. Realising he was missing out on one of the country's biggest stories, he raced to his car and headed downtown. Soon, he'd joined the enormous crowd of reporters gathered around the bank robbers' BMW.
当劳贝尔走进俱乐部的自助餐厅时，他的注意力被一台播放早间新闻的电视机吸引了过去。他第一次得知了过去两天席卷西德的事件。意识到自己错过了国内最大的新闻之一，他冲向汽车，直奔市中心。很快，他就加入了聚集在劫匪宝马车周围的庞大记者群。
Raubel managed to push his way to the car to speak with Rosna and Degofsky directly. He soon established a rapport with the bank robbers. He could tell that both men were growing increasingly agitated and the situation was becoming more dangerous with every passing second. Raubel tried to create some space around the vehicle. He began waving his arms, motioning to the other journalists around him to move back. When they were reluctant to do so, he tried pushing them away. Some of the undercover officers in the crowd began wondering if now was their moment to
劳贝尔设法挤到车前，直接与罗斯纳和德戈夫斯基对话。他很快与劫匪建立了一种默契。他能看出这两个男人越来越烦躁，随着时间的推移，情况正变得越来越危险。劳贝尔试图在车周围腾出一些空间。他开始挥舞手臂，示意周围的其他记者往后退。当他们不愿这样做时，他试图把他们推开。人群中的一些便衣警察开始琢磨现在是不是他们
strike. One officer had succeeded in getting within touching distance of the bank robbers and thought an arrest could be possible, but they suspected the risk was still too great. All of a sudden, Rosna leapt from the car and aimed his gun at the crowd. Anxiously, he turned to Udo Raubel and asked how to get to the Autobahn, adding, We've got to get out of here now, my buddy is about to lose it completely. Raubel began describing the fastest route, but Rosna was impatient. He asked Raubel to get in the car and direct them there himself.
动手的时候了。一名警官成功接近到触手可及的劫匪距离，认为实施逮捕是可能的，但他们怀疑风险仍然太大。突然间，罗斯纳从车里跳出来，把枪对准人群。他焦虑地转向乌杜·劳贝尔，询问如何去高速公路，并补充道：“我们必须马上离开这里，我的伙计快要彻底失控了。”劳贝尔开始描述最快的路线，但罗斯纳很不耐烦。他要求劳贝尔上车并亲自为他们指路。
Raubel was uncertain. The situation was rapidly spiraling out of control and there was every possibility it could end in disaster. However, he also realized that this was a unique opportunity to cover the story in a way none of the other journalists could. In a split second, Raubel had made up his mind. He climbed into the back seat of the car and took a seat next to Silke Bischoff. Rosna slowly pulled the car away from the crowd and left the crowded city streets, following
劳贝尔有些犹豫。局势正在迅速失控，完全有可能以灾难收场。然而，他也意识到这是一个独特的机遇，可以用其他记者无法企及的方式来报道这则新闻。在转瞬之间，劳贝尔下定了决心。他爬上汽车后座，在西尔克·比肖夫旁边坐下。罗斯纳缓缓将车驶离人群，离开拥挤的城市街道，按照
Raubel's directions to the Autobahn. Raubel chatted openly as they drove. He assumed that police had bugged the car and hoped he might be able to coke some useful information out of the two felons. But his attempts at conversation annoyed Degovsky. He pointed his gun at the journalist and demanded that he shut up. After that, the group travelled in silence. The bank robbers had no particular destination in mind as they spared in a southeast direction.
劳贝尔的指示开往高速公路。一路上，劳贝尔侃侃而谈。他假设警察在车里安了窃听器，并希望自己能从这两个罪犯口中套出一些有用的信息。但他的攀谈惹恼了德戈夫斯基。他用枪指着这名记者，要求他闭嘴。此后，这群人一路无话。劫匪们盲目地朝东南方向疾驰，并没有特定的目的地。
Although driving along the Autobahn left them exposed, it also allowed them to monitor those who were following them. Yet again, the press and the police were hot on the bank robbers' heels. Between 20 and 30 vehicles were following the BMW. Law enforcement arranged for the Autobahn to be shut down in one direction so no one else could join the chase. After about 40 minutes, the BMW reached a service station outside the city of Ziegborg. Rosna and Degovsky pulled over and kicked Raubel out of the car, having got what they
尽管沿着高速公路行驶让他们暴露在外，但也让他们能够监控那些尾随他们的人。媒体和警察又一次紧追劫匪不放。20到30辆车尾随着宝马。执法人员安排将高速公路的一个方向封闭，这样就没有其他人能加入追捕。大约40分钟后，宝马抵达齐格堡市外的一个服务区。罗斯纳和德戈夫斯基把车停下，把劳贝尔踢下了车，因为他们已经从他那里得到了
needed from him. The journalist stood watching as the BMW took off again. When news crews arrived at the location shortly after, they conducted a live interview with him. He described Degovsky as, completely on the edge, exhausted and ready for anything. He said that he has nothing to lose. He shot a 15-year-old and is not going to prison for a life sentence. There is going to be a bloodbath if the police don't leave them alone.
需要的东西。记者站在一旁看着宝马再次疾控而去。不久后新闻摄制组抵达现场，并对其实施了现场采访。他将德戈夫斯基描述为“彻底崩溃、精疲力竭且准备孤注一掷”。他说他“没有什么可失去的。他枪杀了一个15岁的孩子，不会去坐无期徒刑的牢。如果警察不放过他们，这里将血流成河。”
He asked me to pass this on to the police and press. As he spoke, Raubel suddenly felt himself go weak at the knees. The reality of what had happened and the fact that he could have been killed, suddenly sunk in. He was notified that police officers were on their way to obtain a statement from him, but all he could think about was the article he planned to write detailing his experience. The BMW continued along the Autobahn. Rosna was driving south, straight towards the neighbouring state of Rhineland, Palatinate.
“他让我把这些转达给警方和媒体。”正说着，劳贝尔突然感到双腿发软。所发生事情的现实以及他本可能丧命的事实突然涌上心头。有人通知他警察正在赶来向他做笔录，但他脑子里想的全是他计划撰写的详细记录他这段经历的文章。宝马继续在高速公路上行驶。罗斯纳一路向南开车，直奔邻近的莱茵兰-普法尔茨州。
As they drove, Degovsky leaned over and whispered in hostage Enos's ear that they were sorry for having taken them, especially given the girl's young age. He told her that he and Rosna would pull over somewhere and release them once they were in the next state and a night had fallen. Enos and Silke felt a sense of relief. They relaxed enough to sip on some cans of beer as the car travelled along the highway, with the two girls drinking a toast to her happy ending. Your enforcement was still in hot pursuit.
车行途中，德戈夫斯基俯身在人质埃诺斯的耳边低声说，他们对绑架她们感到抱歉，特别是考虑到这个女孩年纪还小。他告诉她，一旦进入下一个州且夜幕降临，他和罗斯纳就会在某个地方停车释放她们。埃诺斯和西尔克感到一阵释然。随着汽车在公路上行驶，她们放松下来，甚至喝了几罐啤酒，两个女孩为圆满的结局干杯。执法人员仍在紧追不舍。
By now, it had been 54 hours since the bank holed up in Gladbeck and patience was wearing thin. Police had missed one opportunity after another to apprehend the bank robbers. The fact that they'd killed a 15-year-old in cold blood proved how dangerous they were. An order had finally been sent from operational headquarters, dictating that they mustn't be allowed to flee to any more cities. The perpetrators must be apprehended as soon as possible. The leader of Cologne's SE car unit objected, believing that the risk to the hostages was
此时，距离匪徒盘踞格拉德贝克已经过去54小时，大家的耐心正在耗尽。警察接连错过抓捕劫匪的机会。他们冷血地杀害一名15岁少年的事实证明了他们有多么危险。指挥部终于下达了一项命令，规定绝不能让他们逃往更多城市。必须尽快将行凶者缉拿归案。科隆特别行动队（SEK）队长对此表示反对，认为对人质的风险
still too great, but he was overruled. Several armoured Mercedes were dispatched with the aim of intercepting the BMW and running it off the road. An ambush site was set up several kilometres from the state line, and just across the border, the Rhineland Paladinate SE car were poised and ready to strike. Before the BMW had been given to Rosna and Dagovsky, police outfitted it with a device that would allow them to cut the engine using a remote control. However, the remote had accidentally been left behind with some other officers who were
依然太大，但他的意见被驳回了。多辆装甲梅赛德斯被派出，目的是拦截宝马并将其逼出公路。一个伏击地点在距离州界几公里的地方设好，而在省界另一侧，莱茵兰-普法尔茨州特警严阵以待准备出击。在宝马交给罗斯纳和达戈夫斯基之前，警察在车上安装了一个装置，可以通过遥控器切断发动机。然而，这个遥控器不小心留在了后面高速公路上的一些其他警察那里。
further back on the autobahn. It wouldn't work from such a distance, and this meant that they'd had to quickly devise a backup plan. By 1.45pm, the BMW was just a few kilometres from the state border. Helicopters were flying overhead, and hundreds of spectators had gathered on a nearby bridge above the highway to observe the pursuit. Hundreds of journalists were also at the scene, still following the story. On the other side of the highway, drivers had stopped their cars so they could watch
从这么远的距离根本无法操作，这意味着他们必须迅速制定一个备用计划。下午1点45分左右，宝马距离州界只有几公里。直升机在头顶盘旋，数百名旁观者聚集在高速上方的一座桥上观看追捕。数百名记者也来到现场，继续追踪报道。在高速公路的另一侧，司机们也把车停下来观看。
too. Suddenly, officers were given the go-ahead to attack. A grey Mercedes zeroed in on the BMW and rammed it from one side, sending it skidding. Next, police threw flash grenades to stun the felons with blinding flashes of light. The BMW came to a complete stop. Inside, Rosna and Dagovsky began shouting. Silke appeared to sense that something awful was about to happen. Her voice was gripped with fear as she screamed at her friend.
突然间，警官们得到了进攻的批准。一辆灰色梅赛德斯锁定宝马并从一侧将其撞击，导致它打滑。接着，警察扔出闪光弹，用刺眼的强光让罪犯目眩。宝马彻底停了下来。车内，罗斯纳和达戈夫斯基开始大喊大叫。西尔克似乎感觉到有什么可怕的事情即将发生。她充满恐惧的声音尖叫着对她的朋友说：
Jump out, Enos. Jump. Enos scrambled to find the handle on the car door nearest to her and yanked it open. She leapt out, then scurried to a nearby ditch and clambered inside. As she lay there, she heard the sound of gunshots ringing out. Rosna, Dagovsky and the police were all shooting at one another. Between 20-30 shots were fired. And finally, there was a heavy silence.
“跳出去，埃诺斯。跳。”埃诺斯手忙脚乱地寻找离她最近的车门把手并猛地拉开。她跳了出去，然后飞奔到附近的一条沟渠里并爬了进去。当她躺在那里时，她听到枪声响起。罗斯纳、达戈夫斯基和警察都在互相射击。开了20到30枪。最后，是一阵沉重的死寂。
Police had managed to hit Rosna and Dagovsky, subduing both men. When they raced over to the BMW, they found the two felons had sustained significant injuries. Enos Vojla had managed to escape the vehicle and was lying in a ditch by the road. She'd suffered minor injuries, as had Marion Lerblek. Silke Bischoff was still in the back seat of the car. There was a bullet wound in her chest. An officer frantically performed CPR on Silke as medical assistants, helicopters and ambulances sped to the scene.
警察成功击中了罗斯纳和达戈夫斯基，制服了这两个男人。当他们冲向宝马时，发现两名罪犯都受到了重伤。埃诺斯·沃伊拉成功逃离车辆并躺在路边的沟里。她受了轻伤，马里昂·勒布利克也是如此。西尔克·比肖夫仍然坐在汽车后座上。她的胸部有一处枪伤。当医务人员、直升机和救护车疾驰赶赴现场时，一名警官拼命对西尔克实施心肺复苏。
When they arrived, they rushed to the car while shouting at the police. What have you guys done here? They were unable to revive Silke. She had been shot directly in the heart and had died. Her body was covered with a sheet. Rosna and Dagovsky were quickly handcuffed and forced to lie face down on the road with their noses pressed against the bitumen. Marion Lerblek was also arrested.
他们到达后，冲向汽车并向警察大喊：“你们在这里做了什么？”他们没能救活西尔克。她直接中弹击中心脏，已经身亡。她的遗体被一块床单盖住。罗斯纳和达戈夫斯基迅速被戴上手铐，被迫脸朝下趴在马路上，鼻子紧贴着柏油路面。马里昂·勒布利克也被逮捕。
Other officers made a beeline towards the many members of the press who were standing nearby, filming and photographing everything. A photographer had his camera snatched from him, with the officer alleging that he was documenting a police investigation without permission. The photographer was warned that he would be arrested if he didn't leave. He managed to hide a roll of film that he'd already shot, but lost the second roll that was still inside the camera. A police spokesperson addressed the press, informing them that a hostage had been killed.
其他警官则径直冲向站在附近拍摄和记录一切的众多媒体成员。一名摄影师的相机被抢走，警官指控他在未获许可的情况下记录警方调查。该摄影师被警告如果不离开就会被逮捕。他设法藏了一卷已经拍过的胶卷，但丢失了仍在相机里第二卷。警方发言人向媒体发表讲话，通报了一名人质被杀的消息。
Journalist Udo Rorbell had gone to a local police station to file a report about his time with the bank robbers when he heard the news that Silke Bischoff had died. He felt a sense of shock wash over him, having been seated in the car with both girls not long earlier. When he later went back to his office to finish his article for the following day's paper, he tried to write it from the point of view of Silke, imagining how the last moments of her life played out. Silke Bischoff's parents hadn't even known that their daughter had been taken hostage
记者乌杜·罗贝尔前往当地警察局就他与劫匪在一起的经历做笔录时，听到了西尔克·比肖夫身亡的消息。一股震惊感向他袭来，不久前他还和两个女孩坐在车里。当他后来回到办公室为次日的报纸完成文章时，他试图从西尔克的角度来写，想象她生命最后时刻的情景。西尔克·比肖夫的父母甚至都不知道他们的女儿被劫为人质
until earlier that day. Although she hadn't returned home on Wednesday, August 17, they weren't concerned, as they believed she was staying at her boyfriend's house. They'd only learnt the truth that morning upon seeing the front page of their local newspaper. It showed a photograph of Silke sitting in the back seat of a car with a gun held to her neck. She was tilting her head back, her expression blank, as Dagovsky watched her with a cigarette
直到那天早些时候。尽管她周三（8月17日）没有回家，但他们并不担心，因为他们以为她在男友家过夜。他们直到那天早晨看到当地报纸的头版才得知真相。上面登了一张西尔克坐在汽车后座上的照片，一把枪正抵着她的脖子。她把头向后仰，表情茫然，而达戈夫斯基嘴里叼着烟看着她。
hanging from his mouth. After that, her devastated family had monitored every second of the situation. When Silke's mother, Karen, found out her daughter and Dennis were the last two remaining hostages, she became utterly terrified at what might happen next. When the family saw footage of the collision and subsequent shootout on the auto barn, they sat together and prayed for Silke to survive. Two hours later, a police representative dressed entirely in black knocked on their front door. Karen knew then that her daughter had been killed.
此后，她崩溃的家人监控了情况的每一秒。当西尔克的母亲卡伦发现女儿和丹尼斯是最后剩下的两名人质时，她对接下来可能发生的事情感到极度恐惧。当一家人看到高速公路上碰撞及随后的枪战画面时，他们坐在一起祈祷西尔克能生还。两个小时后，一名身穿全黑衣服的警察代表敲响了他们家的大门。卡伦那时就知道她的女儿已经遇害了。
She later despaired. I would have helped her if only I knew. I would have jumped on the bus, together with my husband, to protect my daughter. It was determined that Silke had been killed by a bullet from Rosena's gun, which he'd accidentally aimed at her while shooting at the police. But Silke's family held the police equally responsible for their daughter's death. They couldn't understand why officers had opened fire on the bank robber's vehicle when they knew that Silke was inside.
她后来绝望地说：“我要是早知道的话就会去救她了。我会和丈夫一起跳上大巴，来保护我的女儿。”经查明，西尔克是被罗斯纳枪里的子弹杀害的，当时他在向警察开枪时失手打中了她。但西尔克的家人认为警察对他们女儿的死负有同等责任。他们不明白为什么警官在明知西尔克在车里的情况下还要向劫匪的车开火。
Her mother criticised their actions, quote, she could not survive that. Why did they do that? Why? That will always stay with me, always. The police maintained that Rosena and Dagovsky had started shooting first, leaving them with no option but to return fire. Furthermore, they claimed to have made every effort to protect those inside the vehicle, such as by waiting until the BMW was stationary before ramming it.
她的母亲批评了他们的行为，原话是：“她不可能在那种情况下生还。他们为什么要这么做？为什么？这将永远留在我的记忆中，永远。”警方坚称罗斯纳和达戈夫斯基先开枪，这让他们别无选择只能还击。此外，他们声称已尽一切努力保护车内人员，例如等到宝马停稳后才对其进行撞击。
But their version of events was disputed by survivor Enos Voitler. In an interview with the magazine Der Spiegel, Enos said that before the deadly confrontation, the mood in the BMW had been upbeat. She and Silke had been assured by their captors that they would be safely home soon. The car had been travelling at 100km per hour when the police's Mercedes suddenly appeared from behind, causing Rosena and Dagovsky to panic. Then the car hid ours. Our car had stopped by the time the gangsters returned the fire.
但幸存者埃诺斯·沃特勒对他们的说法提出了质疑。在接受《明镜》杂志采访时，埃诺斯表示，在致命对峙发生前，宝马车内的气氛一直很轻松。她和西尔克得到绑架者的保证，说她们很快就能安全回家。当时汽车正以每小时100公里的速度行驶，这时警察的梅赛德斯突然从后面出现，导致罗斯纳和达戈夫斯基惊慌失措。然后汽车撞上了我们。当歹徒还击时，我们的车已经停下了。
There was speculation that police from North Rhine-Westphalia had rushed the attack because they wanted to bring the crisis to a conclusion on their own turf. If the bank robbers had managed to flee across the state border, the case would have passed over to law enforcement in Rhineland-Palatinate. On Sunday, August 21, three days after Silke's death, her uncle, Girold Bischoff, appeared at a press conference to announce his family's plans to sue those who ordered the attack. Emmanuella de Georgie's relatives joined them, arguing that the police had provoked the two bank robbers by arresting Marion Lerblik without permission.
有猜测称，北莱茵-威斯特法伦州的警察之所以急于发动进攻，是因为他们想在自己的地盘上结束这场危机。如果劫匪设法逃过州界，案件将移交给莱茵兰-普法尔茨州的执法部门。8月21日星期日，即西尔克死后三天，她的叔叔吉罗尔德·比肖夫出席了一场新闻发布会，宣布其家人计划起诉下令发动袭击的人。埃曼纽拉·德·乔治的亲属也加入了他们的行列，辩称警察在未获批准的情况下逮捕马里昂·勒布利克，从而激怒了两名劫匪。
A week after the incident, lawyers on behalf of the two families filed criminal negligence suits against police in Bremen and the state of North Rhine-Westphalia. They argued that police had numerous opportunities when they could have intervened and placed the two perpetrators under arrest, but repeatedly failed to do so. The families weren't the only ones who were angry. In the days immediately following the tragedy, a poll was cast in which 1,708 Western Germans were asked for their opinions on the case. 93% of respondents couldn't understand why police hadn't intervened earlier.
事件发生一周后，代表两个家庭的律师对不莱梅警方和北莱茵-威斯特法伦州政府提起了过失犯罪诉讼。他们辩称，警方有多次机会可以进行干预并将两名行凶者逮捕，但却屡屡错失良机。愤怒的不止这些家属。在悲剧发生后的几天里，一项民意调查显示，1,708名西德人被问及对该案的看法。93%的受访者无法理解为什么警察没有早点干预。
One SE car senior official who'd been tasked with handling the crisis was Reiner Kesting. He was furious at the unit's operations management for not allowing his team to strike against Rosna and Degofsky earlier. Management had continually stalled officers on the ground from taking action when the two men were stopped in Cologne for an extended period. Kesting was an experienced officer who'd successfully arrested notorious terrorists in the past. But his dismay at the bungling of the Glatbeck hostage crisis led to his resignation.
负责处理危机的SEK高级官员之一是莱纳·克斯廷。他对行动管理层不允许他的团队早点对罗斯纳和Degovsky采取行动感到愤怒。当这两个人在科隆长时间停留时，管理层不断拖延现场警察采取行动。克斯廷是一名经验丰富的警官，过去曾成功逮捕过臭名昭著的恐怖分子。但他对格拉德贝克人质危机处理不当的失望导致他愤而辞职。
Decades later, he finally gave an interview to Focus magazine, in which he stated, I was a coward. I am jointly responsible for the death of Silke Bischoff. A parliamentary inquiry was ordered into the events surrounding the 54-hour long crisis. It found that there had been several times when police missed opportunities to take down the perpetrators, prior to the bus hijack and the deaths of Emmanuella, Silke, and the police officer who was killed during the car chase. There was the time when they stopped at a roadside cafeteria with the two bank employees
几十年后，他终于接受了《焦点》杂志的采访，并在采访中表示：“我当时是个懦夫。我对西尔克·比肖夫的死负有共同责任。”有关部门下令对这起持续54小时的危机背后的事件进行议会调查。调查发现，在巴士被劫持以及埃曼纽拉、西尔克和在汽车追逐中丧生的警察牺牲之前，警方曾多次错过拿下行凶者的机会。有一次是他们在路边自助餐厅同两名银行员工停下
and sat at a separate table. Then there was the occasion when Rosna and Ulurblik went shopping for an hour, leaving Degofsky behind with the two hostages. Degofsky had dozed off, but the police surveilling the scene neglected to notice. Martin Thomas, who was part of the investigation committee, later stated, It was very hard to understand the actions of the police. You ask yourself why they didn't do anything earlier, and all of a sudden go into action when the lives of the two girls are at such a high risk.
并坐在不同的桌子旁。还有一次是罗斯纳和乌勒布利克去购物了一个小时，把德戈夫斯基和两名人质留在了后面。德戈夫斯基打了个盹，但监视现场的警察却疏忽大意没有注意到。调查委员会成员马丁·托马斯后来表示：“很难理解警察的行为。你会问自己为什么他们早些时候什么都不做，而当两个女孩的生命处于如此高风险时却突然采取行动。”
Some officers defended their actions, saying that it was easy to judge with the benefit of hindsight, but they'd tried everything possible to end the crisis safely. Many people were equally as angry at the media for their role in the event. In a televised interview, the Interior Minister of the state of North Rhine-Westphalia accused the journalists of derailing crucial police operations. He saw the final showdown between law enforcement and the bank robbers as unavoidable, given how drawn out and increasingly dangerous the situation had become. Other politicians echoed his words, with one remarking that it was troubling that,
一些警察为他们的行动辩护，称事后诸葛亮很容易，但他们已经尽了一切可能来安全结束危机。许多人同样对媒体在这起事件中所扮演的角色感到愤怒。在电视采访中，北莱茵-威斯特法伦州内政部长指责记者破坏了关键的警方行动。鉴于局势变得越来越漫长和危险，他认为执法部门与劫匪之间的最终对决是不可避免的。其他政客也附和他的言论，其中一位评论说，令人不安的是，
Two criminals got a public podium through media coverage. Reporters were seen as having encouraged Rosna and Dagovsky in their crimes by giving them attention and notoriety. Ratings later revealed that 13 million people had tuned in to watch their televised interviews. A forensic psychiatrist later speculated that the attention had been gratifying for the two men, who'd never received anything like it before. The head of the country's largest journalist's union described the media's involvement as the darkest hour of German journalism since the end of World War II.
两个罪犯通过媒体报道获得了一个公众讲台。记者被认为通过给予罗斯纳和达戈夫斯基关注和恶名，助长了他们的罪行。收视率后来显示，有1300万人收看了他们的电视采访。一名法医精神病学家后来推测，这种关注对这两个从未得到过类似关注的人来说是一种满足。该国最大记者工会的负责人将媒体的参与描述为自二战结束以来德国新闻业最黑暗的时刻。
Following the controversial coverage of the crisis, the German press council issued several reprimands and introduced restrictions, such as banning reporters from conducting interviews with perpetrators while they were in the process of committing a crime. Journalist Udu Raubel was offered a new job at one of the country's biggest tabloids. He felt significant guilt for his actions during the Gladbeck crisis. He was especially ashamed of having written a story that focused on the moments leading up to Silke's death, which he described as squeezing the very last drops out of the story. Years later, in an interview with the BBC, Raubel said he'd often wondered if he was
在该危机的争议性报道之后，德国新闻理事会发布了多次申斥并出台了限制措施，例如禁止记者在犯罪分子作案过程中对其进行采访。记者乌杜·劳贝尔被该国最大的小报之一提供了一份新工作。他对自己在格拉德贝克危机期间的行为感到深深的内疚。他尤其为撰写了一篇聚焦于西尔克临终前最后时刻的文章感到羞耻，他将此描述为“榨干了故事的最后一滴水”。多年后，在接受BBC采访时，劳贝尔表示他经常想自己到底是
the reporter from hell or simply a human being trying to de-escalate the situation. Ultimately, he concluded that he was both. It was almost one year before Hans Jürgen-Rosner, Dieter Degovsky, and Marion Lerblik first faced court to hear the charges against them. They were each facing two counts of murder and numerous charges of attempted murder, kidnapping, and extortion. Also in the court were the victims' families and survivors of the Gladbeck hostage crisis, who listened intently to the proceedings.
来自地狱的记者还是仅仅一个试图缓和局势的人类。最终，他得出结论，他两者都是。将近一年后，汉斯-于尔根·罗斯纳、迪特尔·德戈夫斯基和马里昂·勒布利克才首次出庭听取针对他们的指控。他们每人都面临两项谋杀罪指控以及多项谋杀未遂、绑架和敲诈勒索罪名。出庭的还有受害者家属和格拉德贝克人质危机的幸存者，他们聚精会神地聆听诉讼程序。
The three defendants' expressions remained blank as each charge was read aloud. It was another two years before their trials went ahead. All three were found guilty on March 22, 1991. Rosner and Degovsky both received life sentences with a minimum of 24 years, while Lerblik was sentenced to nine years. She ultimately served only six and has since been released. The North Rhine Vestphalian Ministry of Justice blocked all requests for interviews with Rosner and Degovsky, but the two have shown no interest in speaking to journalists since the events
宣读每项罪名时，三名被告的表情都十分木然。又过了两年，他们的审判才得以进行。三人于1991年3月22日均被判有罪。罗斯纳和德戈夫斯基均被判处无期徒刑，至少服刑24年，而勒布利克则被判处9年监禁。她最终只服刑了6年，此后已被释放。北莱茵-威斯特法伦州司法部拒绝了所有采访罗斯纳和德戈夫斯基的请求，但自1988年8月事件发生以来，这两人一直对与记者交谈表现得毫无兴趣。
of August to 1988. In 2017, news broke that Degovsky had permission to leave prison for day trips. The process was a stage in his rehabilitation and designed to prepare him for being granted conditional parole. Reporters for tabloid papers snapped photographs of him as he strolled through a town, purchasing snacks and soft drinks. He was now 61 years old and was bald with a porgy build. In August 2018, 30 years after the Glatbeck hostage crisis, it was announced that Dieter
2017年，有消息爆出德戈夫斯基获准出狱进行一日游。这一程序是他改过自新阶段的一部分，旨在为他获得有条件假释做准备。小报记者抓拍到他在小镇漫步、购买零食和软饮料的照片。他当时61岁，已经秃顶且身材发福。2018年8月，即格拉德贝克人质危机30周年之际，官方宣布迪特尔·德戈夫斯基获准假释。他在服刑期间一直是模范囚犯，专家对他重返社会的预后给出了积极评价。他此后改了名字。
Degovsky was being released on parole. He'd been a model prisoner during his incarceration and experts gave him a positive prognosis for rehabilitation. He has since changed his name. That same year, it was announced that Hans-Jürgen Rosner would likely be released in 2019, pending good behavior. Degovsky's parole coincided with the release of a two-episode television drama about the crisis titled, 54 Hours, The Glatbeck Hostage Crisis.
同年，据宣布汉斯-于尔根·罗斯纳若表现良好也有望于2019年获释。德戈夫斯基的假释恰逢一部关于该危机的两集电视剧上映，该剧名为《54小时：格拉德贝克人质危机》。
Some survivors and victims' families were dismayed by the timing of the show's release. Johnny had been six years old when the bus he was riding on was hijacked by Rosner and Degovsky. His family had recently moved to West Germany from Schalanker and the experience was incredibly traumatic for the young boy. Now a doctor, he said that he had never quite recovered from the incident. He gave an interview on a late-night talk show, saying that he had no plans to watch the series because it's like a homage to Degovsky, who has now been freed.
一些幸存者和受害者家属对该剧播出的时机感到沮丧。约翰尼在乘坐的大巴被罗斯纳和德戈夫斯基劫持时只有六岁这段经历对这个年轻男孩来说是一场难以置信的创伤。如今已是一名医生的他说，他从未完全从这起事件中恢复过来。他在一档深夜脱口秀节目中接受采访时表示，他没有计划观看这部剧集，因为“这就像是在向已经获释的德戈夫斯基致敬”。
Emanuella de Giorgi's family also spoke out against Degovsky's release. His brother, Fabio, now aged 40, stated, He is free while will suffer for a lifetime. I often dream of Emanuella. He's sitting in the bus and then the shot comes and I wake up. Emanuella's sister, Tatiana, who'd witnessed his murder, revealed she could still hear him whispering to her, Don't be scared, I'll protect you. Enos Voitler feared for years that when the men were released they would turn up at her
埃马努埃拉·德·焦尔吉的家人也公开反对释放德戈夫斯基。他的弟弟法比奥现年40岁，表示：“他自由了，而我们将痛苦一生。我经常梦到埃马努埃拉。他坐在公交车上，然后枪声响起，我就醒了。”埃马努埃拉的妹妹塔蒂亚娜目睹了谋杀过程，她透露自己仍能听到他对她耳语：“别害怕，我会保护你的。”埃诺斯·沃特勒多年来一直担心这些男人释放后会找上门来，
front door, stating, I will always be a victim of those two guys. In an interview with news magazine De Stern, Silke Bischoff's mother, Karen, spoke of watching the television series. It felt as though she was seeing her daughter again. One of the most difficult parts was seeing the recreation of Degovsky holding a gun to her daughter's neck. In reality, journalists had helped to stage the scene and it resulted in a notorious photograph that was splashed across newspapers in the wake of Silke's death. Karen told the BBC,
她站在前门说道：“我永远是那两个家伙的受害人。”在接受新闻杂志《明镜》采访时，西尔克·比施霍夫的母亲卡伦谈到了观看这部电视剧的感受。这感觉就像她再次看到了女儿。最艰难的部分之一是看到德戈夫斯基用枪指着她女儿脖子的重现场景。实际上，记者们曾协助摆拍了这一场景，并拍下了一张臭名昭著的照片，在西尔克死后刊登在各大报纸上。卡伦告诉BBC，
Silke was brave, very brave. I wouldn't have coped in the way she did. At the beginning I used to have nightmares because of that picture. I can handle it today, it's still painful, but I don't have to look away now. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
“西尔克很勇敢，非常勇敢。我无法以她那种方式挺过去。一开始，因为那张照片，我经常做噩梦。今天我能应付了，虽然还是很痛，但我现在不用把目光移开了。”本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。